[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
association
[Music]
in less than six months between 1952 and
1953
we successfully fused nuclei
and caused an island in the pacific to
disappear as well as we entered the
cell and found the three-dimensional
structure of dna and the genetic code 10
years after
we're going to die here
very soon and by soon i mean
a few hundred years at most almost
certainly we're having a cigar party and
a fireworks display while perched on a
propane tank
um you can see from for example the fact
that we're all wearing these masks
people haven't even figured out that
they're going to have to buy hazmat
suits if we start having thermonuclear
exchanges i'm not kidding at all about
this
um so the new reason to do this isn't
the beauty of gazing into the night sky
or man's quest to know uh
his place in the universe if we don't
figure out how to spread out we are
running one single experiment with
god-like powers and the wisdom of morons
uh based on our current political
leadership there is no way that this
terminates well furthermore there is no
faster than light travel inside of
general relativity so you can look up at
the night sky and you can know more or
less that unless you're betting on time
dilation and other exotic effects and
wormholes
we aren't going any place there are only
three habitable spheres
now bezos and musk are focused on
rockets to get us into space one of us
thinks that we can diversify with three
spheres the other seems to think the
gerald k o'neill's circular space
stations with artificial gravity are the
way to go bezos actually makes more
sense neither of these make much sense
at all
if we could only get physics to be
vaguely phallic
in shape loaded with high explosives and
oxidizers we could get fully funded and
i think we'd probably have a theory
within 20 years at the moment nobody
seems to be motivated on the idea that
you break it you bought it
physics has a ton of social
responsibility
we unleashed this power i encourage
everyone to read edward teller's letter
to leo zillard at the end of the
manhattan project his idea was is that
war had to become so unthinkable that we
could never have another
and 75 years of this piece have dulled
our sensibilities forgetting that
nuclear weapons have not gone away and
we've added biologicals if we're not
very careful we're going to have to go
farther through the valley of death that
physics has led us into if we are ever
to escape diversify and have some hope
that some of us at least will make it in
the long term
[Music]
you